ququalité de l'air on a fait des
tetests non passés avec médicaux
sosont déclassés -2500 ppm. Le 2
c'c'est un peu technique mais ls
exexperts nous dise qu'à moins e
151500 ppm la ventilation est
cocorrecte. Il y avait des class
plplus problématiques et on s'en
esest occupé. A beaucoup de
trtravaux qui ont été faits
leles travaux se font encore
auaujourd'hui et demain pour ête
prprêts pour la rentrée des
clclasses
esest-ce que les- est-ce que les
paparents vont avoir...
- - des informations effectivemt
popour avoir des résultats de
lelecteurs de CO2 il faudra les
dédéployer et les installer
l'l'objectif c'est d'être capabe
dede dans ici là les problèmes
onon a testé la qualité de la ds
lala grande partie la majorité
dédéclassée à pas de problème.
LeLes agissements ont été faits
dadans d'autres classes.
OnOn est en fin de parcours icin
esest en train de commencer les
ininitiatives.
- - Je comprends ce que vous me
ddîtes Monsieur Robert pour vous
enendosser régler la ventilatio?
- - Ce n'est pas tout à fait réé
àà des travaux qui se font
enencore. Le déploiement de
lelecteurs de CO2 va se faire ds
amamis des lecture et on fera ds
ajajustements dans les classes e
mamanière exceptionnelle.
AuAujourd'hui je me consens sure
plplan de la rentrée scolaire le
fafait que les jeunes vont devor
poporter les masses dans les
cocommunes et vont les enlever n
clclasse en respect des
cocondamnations de la Santé
pupublique.
- - Je pose des questions que ls
réréponses pour le plan c'est qi
s's'il y a un cas dans une clas.
EsEst-ce que toute la classe
reretrouve à la maison puis on
fafait Nicolas DIX30 comment vos
vovoyez ça6
- - ... ce que nous dit c'est
ququ'on ne pourra pas copier
cocoller les musées de Nantes
papassé à cette année. L'arrivée
dede la vaccination dans les
fafamilles pour les parents pour
leles adolescents et c'est un bu
susuccès la campagne de
vavaccination, vont nous permete
d'd'avoir des mesures différents
cocomme le dit Monsieur... et
seseront moins agressifs pour la
SaSanté publique. Quand c'est le
tetemps de décider de quelle
vivision va faire est-ce qu'il
fafaudra isoler autant d'élèves.
OnOn attend des réponses plus
dédétaillées dans les prochains
jojours sur les protocoles à
memettre en place quand y aura s
cacas possibl dans les classes.
- - Je vais vous le montrer à
l'l'écran si votre enfant a des
sysymptômes vous le gardait à
l'l'anneau vous le factuellement
2424 est-ce que ça tient toujous
leles règles change à ce niveau-
llà?
Y-Y- y aura de nouveaux aide-
mémémoire envoya les parents
onon a appris beaucoup au course
lala dernière année non comme
gogouvernement mais aussi la
scscience appris beaucoup donc n
auaura sans doute une des plus
plplus simplifiées. Il faut
dedemeurer vigilant et prudent e
n'n'est pas le retour à la norme
mamais on peut s'attendre....
- - ça c'est grâce à la vacation
vava regarder les taux de
vavaccination
- - pour la première dose on est
rerendu à Scatrut de pour la
BrBraidot deuxième dose on est à
4848 % mais si on ajoute les ges
ququi ont déjà pris un rendez-vs
çaça grimpe à 67 %.
EsEst-ce que c'est satisfaisant
popour vos 82 % pour la première
dodose est de 48 % deuxième dos?
- - Je pense que c'est très très
bibien mais on fait un bilan des
prprochaines semaines on attend
papas la rentrée scolaire avant
d'd'accentuer la campagne de
vavaccination pour nos adolesces
etet dans les quartiers Hossa
rérépondaient moins bien. Je sas
quque la Santé publique va
ororganiser dans les prochains
jojours des campagnes de
vavaccination ciblée avant mêmea
rerentrée scolaire est une chose
esest certain c'est qu'on va
trtravailler notre opération
j'j'appelle ça opération
cocollaboration dès la rentrée
scscolaire en va organiser aussi
leles campagnes de vaccination
dadans les milieux scolaires avc
lele concours mil scolaire. On
prprend des autobus pour aller u
soson des vaccinations. Ça
grgrimpait aussi les taux de.
- - Mais les élèves n'auront pas
totout le même avantage.
VoVous agissez certaines
acactivités?
- - Sur les
MoMothibaaurisque.Effectivementm
memecequisepasselesadultesetaur'
apapplicationd'unpasseportvaccil
popourparticiper à des sports qi
seseront susceptibles de
prpropager... ces adolescent
fafaites-vous vacciner pour
paparticiper aux affidés...
- - c'est donc votre argument?
- - C'est aussi une condamnation
dede la Santé publique capable e
pepermettre à nos jeunes de faie
leles activités. Avant la pensée
sosoit fondée des parascolaires.
SoSon intérêt